existen otros niveles más altos de
regulación que suceden por aquí y
empezamos a hablar de ellos cuando
mencionamos nuestra proteína rv entonces
el control del ciclo celular sucede en
un nivel más alto con un par de
proteínas clave además de le rêve una de
las proteínas principales de las que
hablaremos que regula en un nivel muy
alto es de 53 cuyo apodo es el guardián
del genoma es tan importante que la
revista science- la llamó molécula del
año en 1993 ni siquiera la teobromina
molécula principal en el chocolate ha
tenido ese honor así que imagínate qué
tan importante es p 53 es más importante
que el chocolate la proteína p53 se
unirá directamente al adn
para producir las proteínas que bloquean
la progresión del ciclo celular una de
esas proteínas es 21 cuya función es
inhibir la sedecap entonces la sedecap
no podrá activar la replicación del adn
ni activar la mitosis rp es una proteína
que está asociada con la función de p53
y estas proteínas son producidas por
genes supresores de tumores entonces
rp es una proteína que se produce a
partir de un gen supresor de tumor de la
misma manera que p53 lo vamos a escribir
por aquí estas proteínas se producen a
partir de genes supresores de tumores y
es muy importante tener estos genes ya
que si están defectuosos o si tienen una
mutación y pierden sus funciones
entonces tendemos a tener cáncer
y creo que estamos de acuerdo que eso no
es nada bueno por lo tanto es muy
importante tener genes supresores de
tumores y para ilustrar qué tan
importante es más del 50% de los tumores
tienen un defecto en p53 rpm se llama de
esta manera debido a que un defecto en
r&b produciría un tumor en el ojo que se
conoce como retinoblastoma de aquí
proviene la r&b es por esto que los
genes para estas dos proteínas se
consideran gene supresores de tumores
por su parte de 21 es muy inusual ya que
no provoca cáncer cuando está defectuoso
en cambio los científicos encontraron
que los ratones que no tienen p 21
tienen la habilidad de regenerar sus
miembros
qué tan raro es esto la carencia de p 21
causa la habilidad de regenerar sus
miembros sus brazos y sus piernas y
todavía se intenta descubrir exactamente
cómo funcionan estas proteínas clave
pero es importante entender que los
genes supresores de tumores son
esencialmente para asegurarnos de que
regulemos el ciclo celular y así no sólo
pasar a la fase de dividir dividir
dividir la célula queremos asegurarnos
de que sólo se va a dividir la célula
cuando sea apropiado cuando la célula
esté lista para ello o incluso de que
sea una célula que se deba dividir en
primer lugar
porque como veremos en nuestros
siguientes vídeos la mitosis o la
división celular requiere mucha energía
y maquinaria proteica por lo tanto
queremos estar seguros de que sea el
momento adecuado para dividirse